MEMBERS AND GUESTS
PLEASE WELCOME THE FORTY OF
GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE HONORABLE GAVIN
NEWSOM.
THANK YOU WE HAVE
SEVERAL HUNDRED YESTERDAY.
PLEASE WELCOME THE FIRST
PARTNER JENNIFER SIEBEL NEWSOM.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS. OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE ALEX PADILLA.
ATTORNEY GENERAL HERE MISTER.
OUR TREASURER FIONA MARK. OR
CONTROLLER THAT HE. PLEASE
WELCOME BACK TO THIS HOUSE THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. AND
ALSO WELCOME BACK THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. WHEN
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
DISTRICT ONE THE HONORABLE TED
GAINES. FROM THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION DISTRICTS TO MALLY
ECHO IN. BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
DISTRICTS THREE TONY VASQUEZ.
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION DISTRICTS
FOR THE HONORABLE MIKE SCHAFER.
WELCOME THE JUSTICES OF THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT THE
CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT TINY
COUNTY SOCCER IT. ASSOCIATE
JUSTICE MING CHIN. ASSOCIATE
JUSTICE CAROL CORRIGAN. SINCE
YOU JUSTICE MARIANA FOURTEEN
ACQUIRE. ASSOCIATE JUSTICE LEON
RECRUITER. AND ISSUE JUSTICE.
JOSHUA GROVE AND- I ALSO WANT
TO WELCOME OUR CONSULAR CORPS
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
FINALLY WELCOME TO ALL OF THE
OTHER DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC
OFFICIALS AND SPECIAL GUESTS
WHO JOINED US HERE TODAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. CALIFORNIA
TWENTY TWENTY IS A TALE OF TWO
STATES IT IS IN DICKENS WORDS
BOTH THE BEST OF TIMES AND THE
WORST OF TIMES. THE BEST IS
REPRESENTED NOT ONLY BY A
STRONG ECONOMY. AND
UNPRECEDENTED INNOVATION BUT BY
THE WORK OF THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY TOGETHER. TOGETHER WE
HAVE MADE HEADWAY ON THE
ENVIRONMENT ON PREDATORY
LENDING. ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. AND GOVERNOR NEWSOME
HAS MOVED FORWARD WITH US. BUT
OUR STRONG ECONOMY AND
UNPRECEDENTED INNOVATION HAVE
BEEN ACCOMPANIED BY SLOW
PROGRESS FOR THE HAVE NOTS. AND
BY UNPRECEDENTED INEQUALITY.
THAT IS THE WORST OF OUR TIMES.
I AM BEGINNING TO IS TO TIRE OF
SAYING IT EACH YEAR BUT WE
STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
WE CAN'T SOLVE OUR HOUSING
CRISIS WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE
ECONOMIC UNDERPINNINGS. ON THAT
SCORE I'M HAPPY THAT LAST
SESSIONS LEGISLATION MADE A
STRONG STATEMENT. IN SUPPORT OF
PROTECTING WORKERS IN THE NEW
ECONOMY. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI ATKINS
AND THE GOVERNOR ON THESE
ISSUES THIS YEAR. TODAY I WALK
IN THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR TO THE
ASSEMBLY TO CHAMBERS NOW IT IS
MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE THE HONORABLE
TONI ATKINS. THE MORNING.
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF MY SENATE COLLEAGUES
AND I WE'RE THRILLED TO JOIN
YOU IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE PARTNERSHIP WORKING
ON BEHALF OF OUR GREAT STATE.
IT IS TRULY MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE CALIFORNIA'S
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AT LANEY
COOL INNOCUOUS. DURING THE
INTERIM LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LED
IN INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND
TRADE DEVELOPMENT INTERAGENCY
COMMITTEE DELEGATION TO MEXICO
TO COLLABORATE ON KEY ISSUES
IMPORTANT TO CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO AND THAT STRONG
RELATIONSHIP. CLEAN TECHNOLOGY
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND ISSUES OF
HEALTH LABOR AND IMMIGRATION. I
WANT TO COMMEND LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR COLDEN OCAS FOR TAKING
ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT EFFORT. AS
THE SENATOR FROM THE THIRTY
NINTH DISTRICT THIS IS AN ISSUE
ABOUT MOST IMPORTANT TO ME AND
TO MY CONSTITUENTS THERE AS
WELL SO THANK YOU. I'M ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR HER COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA'S WORLD CLASS
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
AND IMPRESSED THAT SHE IS
VISITED ALL TWENTY THREE CSU
CAMPUSES AND THE TEN UC'S I
KNOW THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE HER PASSIONATE ENGAGED
SUPPORT FOR THE UPCOMING
LEGISLATIVE YEAR. NOW I'M GONNA
TRY TO SAY IF YOU LINES IN
GREEK BUT FRANKLY LEARNING TO
SAY COOL INNOCUOUS WAS HARD
ENOUGH FOR ME. SO PLEASE FRIEND
DISTINGUISHED PLEASE. JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING OUR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT LOVELY
INTRODUCTION MADAM PRESIDENT
PRO TEM AND- I'M HAPPY TO TEACH
YOU A LITTLE GREEK BUT I THINK
FOR MOST OF US BOB IS REALLY
ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW. LAST YEAR
WE ASSEMBLED IN THIS HISTORIC
CHAMBER FOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
FIRST STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS. BY ALL ACCOUNTS TWENTY
NINETEEN WAS A BUSY YEAR FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT.
LEGISLATION INTRODUCED BY THIS
BODY AND SIGNED INTO LAW BY OUR
GOVERNOR IS ALREADY AT WORK
ADDRESSING HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
WILD FIRES EDUCATION
DISCRIMINATION AND SO MUCH
MORE. WITH OUR ECONOMY STILL
STRONG AND WITH MANY CHALLENGES
STILL LOOMING IT'S CLEAR THE
TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE ANOTHER
LANDMARK HERE FOR CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POLICY. BEFORE I
INTRODUCE THE GOVERNOR I'D LIKE
TO OFFER A WORD OF PERSONAL
GRATITUDE AS A FORMER
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR HIMSELF HE
COULD SEE THE UNDER UTILIZED
CAPACITY AT THIS OFFICE. HIS
SUPPORT HAS STRENGTHENED OUR
WORK IN BOTH PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION AND ON ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES AND LAST YEAR JUST A FEW
WEEKS AFTER TAKING OFFICE HE
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
DESIGNATING ME HIS PERSONAL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND TRADE.
FOREIGN TRADE AND INTERNATIONAL
ENGAGEMENT IS IMPORTANT WORK
ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
CALIFORNIA JOBS DEPENDS ON
TRADE AND TOURISM. CALIFORNIA'S
DEEP WATER PORTS ARE TOURIST
ATTRACTIONS AND ARE ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILE BORDER WITH
MEXICO ARE AMONG THE BUSIEST IN
THE COUNTRY. THIS YEAR WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT FROM THE LEGISLATURE WE
HAVE HELPED TRAIN MORE SMALL
BUSINESSES TO REACH FOREIGN
MARKETS WITH THEIR PRODUCTS WE
HAVE DELIVERED HUMANITARIAN AID
TO HELP ASYLUM SEEKERS AND
WE'VE INCREASED COOPERATION
WITH MEXICO TO FINALLY MOVE
FORWARD TO CLEAN UP THE TIJUANA
RIVER VALLEY AND THE NEW RIVER.
THAT. CALIFORNIA'S VOICE ON THE
WORLD STAGE IS SO IMPORTANT.
THE WORLD IS LOOKING TO WAX NOW
MORE THAN EVER TO LEAD ON THE
CLIMATE AGENDA. YOU ARE SO
DEDICATED TO THIS WORK AND IT A
TIME WHEN SOMEONE THIS COUNTRY
VILIFY IMMIGRANTS THE WORLD
LOOKS TO CALIFORNIA AS WE
CELEBRATE DIVERSE CITY WE KNOW
THAT OUR ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AN
INNOVATIVE SOCIETY COMES HAND
IN HAND WITH BEING THE NUMBER
ONE DESTINATION FOR IMMIGRANTS
TO THE UNITED STATES NUMBER ONE.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME OFTEN SENATE
THE CALIFORNIA IS AMERICA'S
COMING ATTRACTION GOVERNOR THE
VISION THAT THE REST OF OUR
COUNTRY WILL IT EVENTUALLY
CATCH UP WITH CALIFORNIA IS ONE
THAT OFFERS HOPE AND OPTIMISM
TO MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN
COUNTRIES FAR AND WIDE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IT IS MY HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT TO YOU
THE FORTY EIGHT GOVERNOR OF THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PLEASE STAND FOR GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM. THANK YOU. WE. THANK
YOU ALL. I TENDED TO. MAKE SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT BEING LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR. BUT DON'T DO IT ALL
RIGHT I WILL MAKE ANY OF IT
THANK YOU BUT ON THE DATA
GOVERNOR FOR YOUR- YOUR
INTRODUCTION AND THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- FOR WELCOMING
JENNA MEET YOUR HOUSE NOT A PRO
TEM MEMBERS THE LEGISLATURE
FELLOW CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN FOR THE PRIVILEGE.
OF THIS PODIUM. THIS NINE THIS
IS WHERE GOVERNOR STAND BEFORE
YOU AND REPORT WITH PRACTICED
GRANDIOSITY THAT THE STATE OF
OUR STATE IS STRONG AND GETTING
STRONGER. AND LARGELY THAT IS
STILL TRUE. AND YES A LANDING
PROUDLY WE STILL ARE AMERICA'S
COMING ATTRACTIONS. BY ANY
STANDARD IN BY NEARLY EVERY
RECOGNIZABLE METRIC THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS NOT JUST THE
RIDING. BUT IN MANY INSTANCES
LEADING THE COUNTRY INVENTING
THE FUTURE AND INSPIRING THE
NATION. WE REMAIN THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IN
JOIN ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHT
CONSECUTIVE MONTHS OF NET JOB.
SOME THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
JOBS HAVE BEEN CREATED SINCE
THE GREAT RECESSION AND FOUR
MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES CALL
CALIFORNIA THEIR HOME. MORE
THAN HALF MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
U. S. VENTURE CAPITAL STILL
FLOWS THE CALIFORNIA COMPANIES.
AND WE'VE AVERAGED WE'VE
AVERAGED THREE POINT 8% GDP
GROWTH OVER FIVE YEARS AND I
SAY THIS RESPECTFULLY COMPARE
THAT TO THE TWO POINT 5%
NATIONAL GDP GROWTH
CALIFORNIA'S. THINK ABOUT THE
STATE TODAY IT'S AN
ENTERPRISING MODERNIZING
PLURALIZED UNIONIZING NATION
STATE OF OPPORTUNITY THIS. THIS
THE UNDERSCORE THE POINT
CONSIDER THAT ONE IN SEVEN NEW
JOBS ONE IN SEVEN NEW AMERICAN
JOBS ADDED TO OUR ECONOMY JUST
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN HAVE
BEEN CREATED RIGHT HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO
RESPECTFULLY WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
THE BOASTS THE BELIEVES THE
TWEAKS OF WASHINGTON
POLITICIANS TRIPPING OVER
THEMSELVES TO TAKE CREDIT FOR
THE ECONOMY REMEMBER THE REAL
VIP'S OF AMERICANS GA GDP
THAT'S THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND
INVESTORS AND ENTREPRENEURS OR
ACTUALLY PRODUCING THEIR OWN
CALIFORNIA DREAMS. WORKING
TOGETHER WORKING TOGETHER WE
BUILD RECORD RESERVES.
INCLUDING THE LARGEST RAINY DAY
FUND IN STATE HISTORY. W COULD
SEE THAT THE HIGHEST CREDIT
RATING IN NEARLY TWO DECADES
AND WE DISAPPEAR THE INFAMOUS
WALL OF DEBT FOLLOWING THE
PRUDENT PRINCIPLE OF NEVER
SPENDING MORE MONEY THAN WE
TAKE IN. SIMPLY PUT.
CALIFORNIA'S THE ROCKET FUEL
PRIOR POWER IN AMERICA'S
RESURGENCE THAT LET ME BE CLEAR.
BEGAN UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA. NEEDS
TO BE SAID. NO WORRY I'M NOT
GONNA GET MUCH MORE PARTISAN
THAN. I SAID MUCH MORE PARTISAN.
BUT EVEN SO EVEN SO CALIFORNIA
NEVER STAND STILL NEVER REST ON
ITS LAURELS YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
THIS IS THE SPEAKER SPARE LAST
YEAR WE WORKED IN A START
PARTNERSHIP TO ACHIEVE A STARK
PROGRESS TOGETHER WE ADDRESS
SOME OF THE MOST STUBBORN
ISSUES INVOLVED WRITER FUTURES
FOR MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. THOSE
ACHIEVEMENTS CANNOT BE FULLY
APPRECIATED HIS LINE ITEMS IN
THE BUDGET OR BILL NUMBERS THAT
ACROSS THE DESK WE SEE IN THE
BASES OF DREAMERS AND DOERS ALL
ACROSS OUR REMARKABLE STATE AND
IN THE PATIENTS WHO HAVE NEW
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDED BY DOCTORS TO
LOOK LIKE THAT BUT NO THEIR
CULTURE SPEAK THEIR LANGUAGE
AND UNDERSTAND THEIR STORY. IN
THE RESPOND HERS PUTTING BADGES
ON UNIFORMS AND THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE KNOWING THAT NOW
CALIFORNIA HAS THE BEST AND
BEST RESOURCE WILDFIRE PROGRAMS.
IN THE WORKING. IN THE WORKING
PARENTS WITH MORE MONEY IN YOUR
POCKET THANKS TO EXPAND IT PAID
FAMILY LEAVE. THOUSAND DOLLAR
FAMILY TAX BURDEN IN LOWER
COSTS DUE TO TAX FREE DIAPERS
AND TAMPONS. IN A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
IS PLANNING A MORE PROMISING
FUTURE WITH TWO FREE YEARS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. ANY THE
COLLEGE ATHLETES WILL FINALLY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
JUSTLY COMPENSATED FOR THEIR
OWN NAME. ONE AND IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY CENTRAL VALLEY
IT'S FINALLY GETTING ECONOMIC
ATTENTION IT DESERVES AND
COMMUNITIES FINALLY GETTING
SAFE AND CLEAN DRINKING WATER
NEIGHBORHOODS. NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT ARE THAT ARE READING JUST
A LITTLE BIT EASIER THANKS TO
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK
PARTNERSHIP WITH LEADING
AUTOMAKERS. AND IF VOTERS
APPROVE IT WE MAY SOON SEE MORE
SCHOOL BUILDINGS NEWLY FREE OF
LEAD AND TOXIC MOLD THANKS TO A
BI PARTISAN STATE SCHOOL. IN
CITY AFTER CITY HOUSEHOLD AFTER
HOUSEHOLDS THE HARD WORK OF
THIS LEGISLATURE'S MAKING
DREAMS MORE REAL FOR MORE
CALIFORNIANS THAN EVER BEFORE.
YOU KNOW WHAT JUSTICE BRANDEIS
WROTE IN NINETEEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THAT IS SINGLE
COURAGEOUS STATE MAY SERVE AS A
LABORATORY OF DEMOCRACY HE
COULD EASILY HAVE BEEN
REFERENCING CALIFORNIA TODAY.
BUT BECAUSE UNLIKE WASHINGTON
PLUTOCRACY CALIFORNIA'S AND
SATISFIED SERVICING A POWERFUL
FEW ON ONE SIDE OF THE VELVET
ROPE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM IS
FOR ALL. INTO THAT AND JUST
THINK ABOUT THIS THERE ARE ONE
POINT SIX MILLION FEWER
CALIFORNIANS TODAY LIVING IN
POVERTY THEN THERE WERE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ELEVEN THAT'S ONE
QUARTER OF THE NATION'S
DECREASE. IN JUST THIS ALONE.
NO MAN A PROGRESS LOW NO AMOUNT
OF PROGRESS CAN CAMOUFLAGE THE
MOST PERNICIOUS CRISIS THOUGH
IN OUR MIDST. THAT'S THE
ULTIMATE MANIFESTATION OF
POVERTY HOMELESSNESS. THAT'S
WHAT I'M DEVOTING TODAY'S
REMARK TO THIS CRISIS. LET'S
CALL IT WHAT IT IS IT'S A
DISGRACE BUT THE RICHEST STATE
IN THE RICHEST NATION
SUCCEEDING ACROSS SO MANY
SECTORS IS FALLING SO FAR
BEHIND THE PROPERLY HOUSE HE'LL
AND HUMANELY TREE SO MANY OF
ITS OWN PEOPLE. EVERY DAY THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM IS DETERMINED
BY THE WRENCHING REALITY OF
FAMILIES CHILDREN AND SENIORS
LIVING ON FED ON A CONCRETE BED.
MILITARY VETERANS WHO WHO WORE
THE UNIFORM OF OUR COUNTRY IN A
FOREIGN LAND ABANDONED HERE AT
HOME. LGBTQ YOUTH FLEEING ABUSE
AND REJECTION FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. FACES
UP TO SPARE FAILED BY OUR
COUNTRY'S LEADERS AND OUR
NATION'S INSTITUTIONS. AS
CALIFORNIA'S WE PRIDE OURSELVES
ON OUR UNWAVERING SENSE OF
COMPASSION AND JUSTICE FOR
HUMANKIND BUT THERE'S NOTHING
COMPASSIONATE ABOUT ALLOWING
FELLOW CALIFORNIANS TO LIVE ON
THE STREETS HUDDLED IN CARS OR
MAKE SHIP IN CAN'T MIX. AND
THERE'S NOTHING AND THERE'S
NOTHING.
THERE'S NOTHING JUST
THERE'S NOTHING JUST AS WELL
ABOUT SIDEWALKS AND STREET
CORNERS THAT AREN'T SAFE AND
CLEAN FOR EVERYBODY. THE
PROBLEM IS PERSISTED FOR
DECADES BECAUSE BY MASSIVE
FAILURES IN OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. THIS INVESTMENT IN OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET. EXACERBATED
BY WIDENING INCOME INEQUALITY
AND CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
SHORTAGE. THE HARD TRUTH IS FOR
TOO LONG WE'VE IGNORE THIS
PROBLEM. WE TURNED AWAY WHEN IT
WASN'T OUR SISTER OR BROTHER
OUR NEIGHBOR OR FRIEND AND WHEN
IT WAS A LOVE ONE. HELP SO
OFTEN WASN'T THERE. BUT MOST OF
US EXPERIENCE ALMOST THIS IS A
PANG OF GUILT. NOT A CALL TO
ACTION. YOU KNOW BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE. TWO THOUSAND
FIVE WHEN WE DID THAT FIRST
POINT IN TIME COUNT. THERE WERE
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE. WERE
GEARED HOMELESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT THOUSAND. IN THAT FIRST
POINT IN TIME CáC THAT'S
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND MORE. THAN
WE HAVE TODAY. AND EVEN AT THAT
PEAK THE STATE DID NOT TREAT
THE ISSUE WITH THE URGENCY
REQUIRED. SINCE THEN IT'S
ALMOST BECOME NORMALIZED RIGHT
CONCENTRATED OVER YEARS AND
SKID ROWS AND TEN CITIES IN IN
BIGURBAN CENTERS. BUT NOW.
IT'S NO LONGER ISOLATED. BACK
SOME OF THE MOST TROUBLING
INCREASES OF OCCURRED IN RURAL
AREAS AND SMALL TOWNS IN REMOTE
PARTS OF OUR STATE. NO PLACE NO
PLACE IS IMMUNE NO PERSON IS ON
TOUCHED. IT TOO OFTEN KNOWING
HE WANTS TAKE RESPONSIBILITY. I
HAVEN'T HEARD LOCAL FISHING
JUST RECENTLY COMPLIED
RECLAIMED SAID LOUDLY NOW MY
PROBLEM. SERVANTS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT ARE TOO BUSY POINTING
FINGERS THE STEP UP AND HELP
THAT'S SHAMEFUL. AFTER ALL
EVERY HOMELESS CALIFORNIA. IT
IS. EVERYTHING WAS CALIFORNIA
LIVING ON THE BOULEVARD OF
BROKEN DREAMS IS A CASUALTY OF
INSTITUTIONAL FAILURES PERSON
IS FALLING THROUGH EVERY
POSSIBLE HOLE IN THE SAFETY NET
LOOK HOMELESSNESS IMPACTS
EVERYONE BUT NOT EQUALLY. SOME
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN MUCH MUCH
MUCH HARDER. URBAN RENEWAL AND
GENTRIFICATION BROKE UP
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
THROTTLE THEIR ABILITIES TO
MOVE INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS
THESE ARE SYSTEMIC ISSUES
ROOTED IN POVERTY AND RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION. BLACK
CALIFORNIA. BLACK CALIFORNIA'S
DEPRIVED 8% OF LA COUNTY
POPULATION BUT 42% OF ITS
ALMOST. A RECENT POLL FOUND
THAT NEARLY ONE HALF ONE OF
EVERY TO LATINOS IN THE STATE
ARE AFRAID THAT THEY OR A
FAMILY MEMBER COULD BECOME
HOMELESS. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN NO LONGER TREAT
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY AS SOMEONE ELSE'S
PROBLEM VERY BELOW AND OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT ARE MUCH EASIER
TO WIN. OR BETTER SUITED FOR
SOUND BITES SO RESPONSIBILITY
AND IT MUST BE THE TOP OF OUR
AGENDA.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS. THE CRISIS WAS NOT
CREATED OVERNIGHT. AND IT'S NOT
GONNA BE SOLVED OVERNIGHT OR
EVEN IN A YEAR. IT IS A STATE
WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENSURE NO CALIFORNIA IS
HOMELESS WE GOT TO REPLACE
CALIFORNIA'S SCATTERSHOT
APPROACH WITH A MORE FOCUSED
CRISIS LEVEL RESPONSE SO IN
ORDER TO MAKE THIS MOMENT WITH
A COMMITMENT IT DEMANDS WERE
COMMITTED TO ADVANCING. A NEW
FRIEND. NUMBER ONE. WE WILL
REDUCE STREET HOMELESSNESS
QUICKLY AND HUMANELY TO
EMERGENCY ACTIONS WE WILL BE
LASER FOCUSED ON GETTING THE
MENTALLY ILL OUT OF TENTS IN
INTO TREATMENT. WE WILL PROVIDE
STABLE FUNDING TO GET
SUSTAINABLE RESULTS. AND WE
WILL TACKLE THE UNDER
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
WILL DO ALL OF THIS. DO ALL
THIS WITH REAL ACCOUNTABILITY
AND REAL CONSEQUENCES. LIST ALL
THE BILL WE START WITH FIRST WE
START WITH EMERGENCY ACTIONS TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN NOW TO
MAKE AN IMMEDIATE TANGIBLE
IMPACT AFTER DECADES OF NEGLECT
AND INADEQUATE RESPONSES WE'RE
PUTTING OUR ENTIRE STATE
GOVERNMENT ON NOTICE TO RESPOND
WITH URGENCY. LAST MONTH I
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER THE
POINT EMERGENCY HOUSING
TRAILERS AND SERVICES FOR
HOMELESS FAMILIES AND SENIORS
THESE FIRST TRAILERS HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED IN OAKLAND. AND LA
COUNTY. THE NEXT. THE NEXT
GROUP OF TRAILERS I'M PLEASED
ANNOUNCED TODAY ARE HEADED AS
WE SPEAK TO SANTA CLARA
RIVERSIDE CONTRA COSTA SO NO MY
COUNTY AND THE CITY OF STOCK.%
THAT SAME EXECUTIVE ORDER BUILT
ON A WORK LAST YEAR TO IDENTIFY
ALL EXCESS STATE LANDS. TODAY
WE ARE MAKING TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX STATE PROPERTIES
VACANT LOTS FAIR GROUNDS
ARMORIES IN OTHER STATE
BUILDINGS TO BE USED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR FREE FOR
HOMELESS SOLUTION. WE ARE READY
TO GO. A LADY. THIS NOW WE'VE
ALSO DIRECTED CALTRANS TO MAKE
BETTER USE OF OTHER ON OCCUPIED
SPACES TO GET HOMELESS HOUSING
UP AS FAST AS POSSIBLE THE WE
HAVE GREAT EXAMPLES WE HAVE
GREAT EXAMPLES UNDER
DEVELOPMENT IN THAT SPACE
ALREADY IN SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND SAN JOSE AND LOS
ANGELES AND WERE ABLE TO MOVE
FASTER THAN EVER. EVER BEFORE
ON THESE LEASES IN THESE LAND
TRANSFERS BECAUSE WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A NEW STRIKE TEAM
ACROSS AGENCIES AND STATE
GOVERNMENT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES CALTRANS SEEKS P. ALL
WITH ONE GOAL AND THAT'S TO
BREAK THROUGH BUREAUCRATIC THAT
BARRIERS SO AS THE STATE MOVES
FAST I ALSO HAVE TO MOVE
TOGETHER WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES WERE BY DEFINITION
CRITICAL ALLIES IN ADDRESSING
THIS EMERGENCY. TWO MONTHS AGO
WE ISSUED A ONE HUNDRED
CHALLENGE TO OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
THE FOCUS ON PART. POPULAR
DRESS WITH INTERNET. DOZENS OF
COMMUNITIES I'M PROUD TO SAY
ACROSS THE STATE ARE STEPPING
UP BUT AS WE CAN THESE A MERCY
WE ALSO HAVE TO LIMIT ALL THESE
ROADBLOCKS TO HOUSING AND
SHELTER LAST YEAR BECAUSE YOUR
LEADERSHIP I WAS VERY PROUD TO
SIGN TO IMPORTANT BILLS ONE
STREAMLINE THE PERMITTING
PROCESS FOR NAVIGATION CENTERS
STATE WHY. AND THE SECOND
EXEMPTED ALL SHELTERS AND
HOMELESS HOUSING FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL ROOM ROOM REVIEW
AND I'M MOST POPULOUS CITY LOS
ANGELES. THIS THIS YEAR I HOPE
THAT WE CAN EXPAND BY WORKING
TOGETHER TO EXPAND THIS LAW AND
EXTENDED TO ALL HOMELESS
SHELTERS IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING
WOW. WE NEED MORE MORE DELAY.
ALSO PUSHING FOR NEW MODELS OF
HOMELESS HOUSING LIKE HOTEL
MOTEL CONVERSIONS AND PRE FAB
AND TINY HOMES. AND AS WE DO
THAT WILL CUT THE RED TAPE TO
GET TO YES ON THESE INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES. WELL WE TAKE
EMERGENCY MEASURES TO INCREASE
SHELTER AND SERVICES WE MUST
ALSO COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESSED
THE HARDEST PART OF THIS
PROBLEM. THAT'S THE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS. THE FOLKS OUT IN THE
STREETS AND SIDEWALKS FOR OVER
A YEAR. WITH COMPLEX BEHAVIOR
HEALTH ISSUES. FOR CENTURIES
THE DEFAULT TREATMENT WAS
CONFINEMENT IN A SILENCE WHERE
PEOPLE DETERIORATED OUT OF
SIGHT. IN THE NINETEEN FORTIES
AND IN THE NINETEEN FIFTIES ARE
OUR NATION BEGAN THE TREND
TOWARDS DE INSTITUTIONALIZATION
WAS NOT A SINGLE POLICY. IT WAS
A SERIES OF POLICIES. OUTRAGE
OVER CONDITIONS IN INSTITUTIONS
AS WELL AS THE CREATION OF NEW
MEDICATIONS LIKE FOR ISN'T THAT
THE- HELP TREAT THE MENTALLY
ILL AND IT SPARKED A MOVEMENT
TO. TREAT PEOPLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES RATHER THAN LOCKING
THEM AWAY. CALIFORNIA PASSED
THE SHORT ACT IN FIFTY SEVEN TO
FUND COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
PUSH. THIS WHERE THE CALLS FOR
AS WELL. PRESIDENT KENNEDY
ENVISION A SYSTEM IN WHICH IN
HIS WORDS THE RELIANCE ON THE
COLD MERCY OF CUSTODIAL
ISOLATION WILL SUBLIMATE WOULD
BE SUPPLEMENTED HE SAID WILL BE
SUPPLEMENT. BY THE OPEN WARM
OPEN ONE OF COMMUNITY CONCERN.
STATE MENTAL HOSPITALS WERE
CLOSED BUT THE PROMISE OF
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH IS
NEVER FULLY REALIZED. STATES
WOULD BURDEN NOW THE
RESPONSIBILITY BUT PROVIDED
LITTLE IN THE WAY OF SUPPORT
LAWS WERE CHANGED TO MAKE IT
HARDER TO COMPEL MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AS WELL. THEN
GOVERNOR RONALD REAGAN SIGNED
THE LETTERMAN PETRA SHORT
ACTING NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
DESIGNED TO END THE
INAPPROPRIATE LIFETIME
COMMITMENT OF PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS. AND CRITICALLY
OFTEN FORGOTTEN IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT DECISION O'CONNOR VERSUS
DONALD RULED THAT MENTAL
ILLNESS ALONE COULD NOT JUSTIFY
A STATE BLOCKING A PERSON UP
AGAINST HIS WILL. ALL OF THESE
CHANGES COINCIDED WITH SAFETY
NET CUTS BLOCK GRANTS AND
TIGHTEN THE ELEVATOR
ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND NINETEEN
NINETIES ALONG WITH THE
WHOLESALE RAZING OF SKID ROW'S
AN SR ROSE WHICH FOR SO MANY
WAS THE ONLY HOUSING OPTION
THEY CAN AFFORD. THE CUBAN OF
IMPACT. MAKE COUNTY JAILS THE
DE FACTO MENTAL HEALTH
INSTITUTIONS. PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WERE LEFT WITH
IN ADEQUATE OPTIONS TO GET THE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE THEY NEED.
IN A POLITICALLY POLARIZED
WORLD. LIBERALS AND
CONSERVATIVES BLAME ONE ANOTHER
FOR THESE FAILURES.
HISTORICALLY SPEAKING BOTH ARE
RIGHT IT'S TIME TO STOP
POINTING FINGERS AND JOIN HANDS
IN A TRANSFORMATIONAL SOLUTION.
LET'S NOT. LET'S TALK ABOUT.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE PROPOSED
CALLING IT'S A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME REFORM OF OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM BASED ON THE OBVIOUS
LONG IGNORED PRINCIPLE THAT
PHYSICAL HEALTH AND BRAIN
HEALTH ARE INEXTRICABLY LINKED
AFTER ALL. AFTER. TEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TEN MILLION
CALIFORNIA'S ONE IN FOUR SUFFER
FROM SOME TYPE OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITION. THIS IS NOT A
NARROW ISSUE. NOR A NEW ONE.
THE DEEPER TRUTH IS THAT OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THOUGH IT'S
BEEN DECIDED TREAT SOME OF OUR
PARTS NOT THE SUM OF OUR PARTS
IN THAT MUST CHANGE. SLAM
PROPOSAL. THIS LANDMARK
PROPOSAL CALLS FOR LEVERAGING
MEDI CAL AS A TOOL TO HELP
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS THE HOMELESS OUR
CHILDREN AND PEOPLE CYCLING IN
AND OUT OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IT'S ABOUT INTEGRATING
CARE TARGETING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND
EXPANDING OUR WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS. STATEWIDE. HEALTHCARE.
HEALTHCARE AND HOUSING CAN NO
LONGER BE DIVORCED AFTER ALL
WHAT'S MORE FUNDAMENTAL TO A
PERSON'S WELL BEING THEN A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD. DOCTORS
DOCTORS SHOULD BE ABLE TO WRITE
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR HOUSING THE
SAME WAY THEY DO FOR INSULIN
AND ANTIBIOTICS. ONE THAT'S NOW
THAT'S THE AIM OF CALLING
TRANSFORMING OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM
AS WE KNOW IT AND WE BACKED IT
UP WITH THE SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUEST TO MAKE IT REAL
THIS YEAR. NOW. COURSE ALL OF
THIS YOU KNOW. ALL THIS ALLIES
IN HINGES ON AN INDIVIDUAL
BEING CAPABLE OF ACCEPTING HELP
TO GET OFF THE STREETS AND INTO
TREATMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE
SOME AS WE KNOW TRAGICALLY OR
NOT THAT'S WHY WE NEED BETTER
LEGAL TOLLS ONES THAT ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HELP PROVIDERS
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY HELP PEOPLE ACCESS
TREATMENT THEY NEED.
CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
THIS MAY HAVE BEEN AHEAD OF
THEIR TIME. BUT TODAY THEY CALL
OPERATE FOR. WE MUST TAYLOR
THESE POLICIES TO REFLECT THE
REALITIES OF STREET
HOMELESSNESS TO DATE WHICH IS
SO DIFFERENT IT WAS FIFTY YEARS
AGO OR EVEN FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
WHEN THESE LAWS WERE ENACTED.
AND WHILE WE MADE PROGRESS
UNLIMITED AND GENERAL
CONSERVATORSHIP LAST YEAR
FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE ARE WARRANTED. ALL
WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF DEEP
RESPECT ALWAYS FOR CIVIL
LIBERTIES AND PERSONAL FREEDOMS
BUT WITH AN EQUAL EMPHASIS ON
HELPING PEOPLE IN THE
LIFESAVING TREATMENT THEY NEED
AT THE PRECISE MOMENT. THEY
NEED IT. WELL CLEARLY IT IS
TIME TO RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS
EXPERTS WHO AGREE THAT
THRESHOLD FOR CONSERVATORSHIP
ARE TOO HIGH AND NEED TO BE
REVISITED. TAKE LAURA'S LAW
WHICH ALLOWS LOVE ONCE AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO ASK COURTS
TO COMPEL THOSE WHO NEED
TREATMENT IN A COMMUNITY BASED
OUTPATIENT CARE THE PROBLEM IS
IT'S TOO HARD TO USE. WE NEED
TO REMOVE SOME OF THE
CONDITIONS IMPOSED ON THE
COUNTIES TRYING TO IMPLEMENT A
LOT SO THEY CAN EXPAND WHO
BENEFITS. IT WOULD HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP WE NEED
AUTHORIZED COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. TO ESTABLISH THESE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ONE THAT WAS
RECENTLY DEVELOPED IN SAN
FRANCISCO LOOK. AT SAID. NOT
NAIVE ABOUT THIS THAT SAID. WE
KNOW THAT THE MOST URGENT ISSUE
IS NO THE LEGAL INABILITY TO
CONSERVE PEOPLE BUT THE ON
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING AND
CARE FOR THOSE WHO MOST NEED. I
RECOGNIZE POLICIES AN EMPTY
PROMISE WITHOUT CREATING MORE
PLACEMENTS. AND ONE CLEAR
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS. IS BY
REFORMING PROPOSITION SIXTY
THREE THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT. IT'S ALL PLEASE STAND UP.
AS WRITTEN AS WRITTEN IT'S
RESOURCES OFTEN DON'T REACH THE
PEOPLE NEED IT THE MOST. NOT
WHEN UP OPPOSING CHANGING THE
FUNDING FORMULA FOR HOW MUCH
EACH COUNTY GETS RATHER REFORM
MUST FOCUS THE FUNDING ON
STREET HOMELESSNESS AT RISK AND
FOSTER YOUTH AND THOSE INVOLVED
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WE NEED TO EXPAND THE KINDS
OF SERVICES IT CAN PAY FOR
SPECIFICALLY ADDICTION
TREATMENT. WE ALSO NEED TO STOP
RESPECT WE NEED TO STOP
TOLERATING OPEN DRUG USE ON OUR
STREETS. DISTILLING WE SHOULD
THE BELL COUNTIES TO SPEND MORE
OF WHAT THEY'VE GOT BY LOWERING
THE 33% RESERVE THRESHOLD THAT
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO HOLD BACK.
THIS. THIS IS INTERESTING. EVEN
WITH THE CURRENT RUSSELL FORTY
OUT OF FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ARE
ABOVE THAT LINE THAT'S OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON SPENT THAT COULD GO
TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREET
AND IN THE TREATMENT SO MY
MESSAGE THIS SPEND YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH DOLLARS BY JUNE
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR OR WILL
MAKE SURE THOSE DOLLARS GET
SPENT. FORTY.
YOU GUYS GET IT
IT'S ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
MATCHING RESOURCES TO RESULTS
FOR TOO LONG THERE WERE NO
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROGRESS
HIGHER SYSTEMS BEEN VOLUNTARY.
I WANT TO THANK MY COUNSEL
HOMELESS ADVISORS FOR BRINGING
CONSEQUENCES TO THE FOREFRONT
OF THIS DISCUSSION. IT'S TIME
TO MATCH OUR BIG HEARTED
EMPATHY WITH TIGHT FISTED
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN JUST THE
LAST TWO YEARS BECAUSE YOUR
LEADERSHIP THE LAST TWO YEARS.
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IT'S BEEN ALLOCATED TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALL HOMES.
NOW THIS INCLUDES SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- MERCY ON THE
STATE THAT YOU RECENTLY
APPROVED. AND UP UNTIL NOW.
STATE EIGHT IS BEEN BLOCK
GRANTED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BY
FORMULA. SPENDING DECISIONS
HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY
UNRESTRICTED IN LOCALLY DRIVEN
BUT RESPECTFULLY. THE PROBLEMS
GOT WORSE. AND THE RESULTS NAY
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES. THIS
MOMENT HE CRIES OUT FOR A NEW
APPROACH IN THE BUDGET I JUST
SUBMITTED I PROPOSED A NEW
APPROACH A NEW CALIFORNIA
ACCESS TO HOUSING FUND IN WITH
IT A WHOLE NEW WAY OF INVESTING
IN HOMELESS SOLUTIONS. WE HAVE
A CLEAR PURPOSE FOR THE SPOT
PAINFUL WHAT WORKS GAP
FINANCING FOR INNOVATIVE
HOUSING MODELS LIKE HOTEL MOTEL
CONVERSIONS AND SECURING MAKE
IT UNITS WHEREVER WE CAN FIND
STABILIZING IN EXPANDING
BOARDING CARE HOMES IN
PREVENTNG HOMELESSNESS IN THE
FIRST PLACE THE RENT SUBSIDIES
AND RAPID RE HOUSING TO HELP
PEOPLE ONE JOB LOSS ONE. AWAY
FROM. WITH THIS NATION'S FIRST
STATEWIDE HOUSING FUND WE CAN
START BRADY TOGETHER STATE AND
PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS AS WELL
AS HEALTH CARE MENTAL HEALTH
AND SOCIAL SERVICES PAIN FOR
HOUSING BUT NOT OVERHEAD BY
CAPPING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OF THE FUNDS AT JUST TEN
PERCENT. THAT'S IMPORTANT. THE
WHOLE IDEA IS TO BE NIMBLE AND
FLEXIBLE INTO A BALL FROM BEST
PRACTICES TO NEXT PRACTICES.
AND ALWAYS WITH AN AYE AND DEEP
REGIONAL COORDINATION AND CLEAR
METRICS NUMBER OF NEW LEASES
SIGN NUMBER OF NEW HOUSING
UNITS CONVERTED OR BUILT NUMBER
OF PEOPLE STABILIZE WITH RENT
SUBSIDIES NUMBER OF PEOPLE
MOVED OFF THE STREETS. AGAIN
STANDING. TO GET US STARTED I'M
ASKING THIS LEGISLATURE TO
INVEST AN UNPRECEDENTED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO GET THIS ONE UP AND
RUNNING BASED ON THE SEVERITY
OF CRISIS WE NEED EARLY
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO SET UP
THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO ENTER
INTO THE CONTRACTS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS NOW AND THAT'S WHY
I'M ASKING YOU NOT TO WAIT
MONTHS. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
MONTHS. THE PUBLIC LAST
PATIENTS I KNOW YOU'VE LOST
PATIENCE I'VE LOST PATIENCE IN
ORDER TO REVERSE DECADES OF
NEGLECT. IN ORDER TO TURN
THINGS AROUND THOUGH. THE
CRISIS THIS DEEP ROOTED ALSO
GONNA NEED MORE THAN JUST ONE
TIME FUNDING. WE'RE GONNA NEED
SIGNIFICANT SUSTAINABLE REVENUE.
I KNOW THIS IS ALWAYS THE
TOUGHEST THING SO IN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS LOOK I'M WORKING I
PLEDGE TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
CLOSELY TO IDENTIFY WHERE THIS
ONGOING REVENUE WILL COME FROM
BUT WE'VE GOT TO FIND IT. TO
PROVIDE SAFER CLEANER STREETS
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT
DESERVE IT'S TIME TO MUSTER THE
POLITICAL WILL TO MEET THIS
MOMENT. PEOPLE CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW THIS ARE DEMANDING BOLD
PERMANENT SOLUTIONS ANYTHING
LESS IS NOT GOING TO GET THE
JOB DONE. IN ORDER TO- GET THE
JOB DONE WE GOT A MATCH THIS
NEW. MONEY WITH A NEW LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS HAD ON REQUIRE.
REQUIRING WATER AND THAT ANY
NEW FUNDING ISN'T REPLACING
EXISTING SPENDING BUT CREATING
NEW SOLUTIONS. SOME HAVE
RECOMMENDED A LEGAL RIGHT TO
SHOP. I KNOW IT'S A PROVOCATIVE
IDEA WHICH IS FORCE THE STATE
TO EXPLORE THE LIMITS OF WHAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN BE
COMPELLED TO DO. BUT RIGHT NOW.
I BELIEVE MUST BE ABOUT
BRINGING GOVERNMENTS TOGETHER
AS WORKING PARTNERS NOT
SPARRING PARTNERS IN A COURT OF
LAW. SO INSTEAD. SO INSTEAD WE
ARE PROPOSING STRICT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMPREHENSIVE
AUDITS IN A DO IT OR LOSE IT
POLICY TO HOLD LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RESPONSIBLE FOR
RESULTS TAKE ACTION. ARE YOU
GONNA LOSE THE NEW FUND. IN
ORDER TO TRACK THE PROGRESS
WE'RE COMMITTED TO DEVELOPING
AND ESTABLISHING A UNIFIED
HOMELESSNESS DATA SYSTEM TO
CAPTURE ACCURATE LOCAL
INFORMATION BECAUSE OF THE END
OF THE DAY ALL KNOW THIS YOU
CAN'T MANAGE WHAT YOU DON'T
MEASURE. IT IS TIME IT'S TIME
FOR THE FAILED POLICY OF NOT MY
PROBLEM TO BE REPLACED WITH ONE
A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY ACROSS
EVERY SECTOR IN EVERY COMMUNITY.
NOW LOOK I'M NOT NAIVE NOT ONE
CITY NOW ONE COUNTY NOT EVEN
ONE STATE CAN SHOULDER THIS
RESPONSIBILITY ALONE THIS IS A
NATIONAL CRISIS. FEDERAL
DECISION MAKING CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS MOMENT. IN OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
MATCH ITS RHETORIC WAS SPECIFIC
CONSTRUCTIVE AND DELIVERABLE
RESULTS. CALIFORNIA HAS. I'LL
REPEAT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO EXTEND IT
SANTA PARTNERSHIP TO WASHINGTON
SEEKING TO JOINTLY ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE HONESTLY THIS PARTNERSHIP
SHOULD BE A GIFT. BUT ANTI
WORDS AND SYMBOLIC GESTURES ONE
MASK A 15% ACROSS THE BOARD CUT
TO HUD'S BUDGET. I'M OLD ENOUGH
MANY YOU ARE IN THIS ROOM AS
WELL. I'M OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER WHEN HUD WAS IN THE
HOUSING BUSINESS AND I'M
HOPEFUL ONE DAY THEY WILL BE
AGAIN. YEAH HAVE TO ROLL YOU
KNOW AFTER ALL HOMELESSNESS IS
IN A BLUE OR RED ISSUE AND
EVERYONE IS A BLIGHT ON THE
SOUL. OF AMERICA. THE COURSE
FUNDAMENTAL BUILDING BLOCK OF
CALIFORNIA SOLUTION. HAS TO BE
MORE HOUSING A COMPREHENSIVE
RESPONSE. YOUR JUST SIMPLY NOT
THE BILL ENOUGH. YOU KNOW WE
DON'T BUILD HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE WE MAY WORSEN THE
HOMELESS CRISIS IT'S A VICIOUS
CYCLE. AND WE ONLY. THE ONLY
SUSTAINABLE WAY OUT OF IT IS TO
MASSIVELY INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
LET'S MOVE ON
HOMELESSNESS WITH OUR COURAGE
ON HOUSING SUPPLY LOOK LAST
YEAR WE MADE A NEW AN HISTORIC
INVESTMENT ABOUT ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
BOOST PRODUCTION WAS PART OF
THE SEVEN PLUS BILLION DOLLARS
YOU ALL APPROVED ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSE WE SECURED NEW JUDICIAL
PRIORITIES AGAINST CITIES THAT
DON'T ZONE PLAN AND YOU KNOW DO
THEIR FAIR SHARE. YEAH HAVE. WE
PROTECT TENANTS LIKE NEVER
BEFORE. FINALLY OUTLINE
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST PEOPLE
THAT HAVE HOUSING VOUCHERS. WE
CREATED. WE CREATED A PERMANENT
FUND TO PROVIDE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO AT RISK TENANTS.
IT IS TOTALLY WE WORK TOGETHER
TO CRACK DOWN ON RENT SPIKES IN
ON JUST A BIG SHINS PASSING THE
NATION'S STRONGEST STATEWIDE
RENTER PROTECTIONS. I WAS A BIG.
THANKS TO YOUR LEADERSHIP LAST
YEAR I WAS PRIVILEGED TO SIGN
EIGHTEEN BILLS TO BOOST HOUSING
PRODUCTION. BUT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN EAGER BOULDER REFORM
HASN'T HAPPENED IF THE CARD IN
PART. LEGITIMATELY APART
BECAUSE OF CONCERNS THAT ARE
NOT MAKE BELIEVE AND MANY OF
OUR LOWEST INCOME RESIDENTS
UNDERSTANDABLY WORRY ABOUT
BEING PUSHED OUT OF THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OF
GENTRIFICATION. MIDDLE CLASS
HOMEOWNERS THEY WORRY ABOUT
THEIR SINGLE FAMILY HOME LOSING
ITS VALUE TO SCARY PROSPECT
GIVEN THE HOUSE IS OFTEN THE
FAMILY'S BIGGEST ASSET THOSE
ARE REAL CONCERNS AND THEY
SHOUL NOT BE BRUSHED ASIDE. AT
THE SAME TIME. WE ALSO KNOW THE
STATUS QUO IS SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE WE'RE NOT BUILDING
ANOTHER HOUSE AND- LOOK AT I
GET CITIES NEED TO MEET THEIR
HOUSING GOALS IN A WAY THAT
MATCHES THEIR COMMUNITY. BUT
DOING NOTHING IS NO LONGER AN
OPTION. LOOK I RESPECT LOCAL
CONTROL BUT NOT AT THE COST OF
CREATING TO CALIFORNIA CLASS
SYSTEM NOT AT THE COST OF
IMPERILING THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING.
WE
GOT A GROUP COMMUNITIES OF
PEOPLE CAN LIVE WORK DRIVE
SPENDING MORE TIME WITH THEIR
FAMILIES LESS TIME IN TRAFFIC.
NINE THIS MEANS. THIS MEANS A
COMMITMENT RIGHT NOW THIS YEAR
THE MAJOR REFORM THAT WILL
ELIMINATE RED TAPE AND DELAYS
FOR BUILDING CRITICALLY NEEDED
HOUSING LIKE AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY HOMES A SPECIALLY NEAR
TRANSIT IN DOWNTOWN. I'M
COMMITTED COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE LEADERS OF BOTH THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY TO
CRAFT AND PASS THESE NEEDED
REFORMS OBJECTIVES ARE CLEAR.
INCREASED DENSITY IN A WAY THAT
PROMOTES EQUITY AFFORDABILITY
AND INCLUSION. INCREASED
CERTAINTY. TO INCREASE
CERTAINLY THAT UNITS PLAN
BECOME UNITS BUILT IN A WAY
THAT RESPECTS ALWAYS OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND LABOR
PROTECTIONS AND A WHOLE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE TO BOTH
OF THESE PILLARS MORE DENSITY
AND MORE CERTAINTY IT IS TIME.
TIME THE CALIFORNIA TO SAY YES
TO HOUSING WE CAN NO LONGER
WAIT. LOSE THE CHALLENGE BEFORE
US. THOSE ARE TOUGH CHOICES BUT
WE GOT TO MAKE A- OVERCOMING
ADVERSITY. IN TACKLING
INTRACTABLE PROBLEMS ARE AS A
GRAINY CALIFORNIA'S CHARACTERS
ARE SUN KISSED COAST IN OUR
BREAD BASKET ABOUT. WITH
HOMELESSNESS I ALSO KNOW THAT
IT CAN BE DONE SO I'VE SEEN
SUCCESS ALONG THE WAY. YOU KNOW
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO. WHEN I WAS
MAYOR SAN FRANCISCO IN THE FACE%
OF LONG ODDS IN STEP OPPOSITION
WE ESTABLISHED PROJECT HOMELESS
CONNECT TO BRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES DIRECTLY TO
THE PEOPLE IT'S BEEN A WHILE
THE SUCCESS ONE ADOPTED IN OVER
NOW TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CITIES ACROSS OUR NATION. LAST
YEAR. BACK THE HOMES CONNECTED
I SPOKE WITH A MAN. BY THE NAME
OF RICHARD OR LEAVE. FOUR YEARS
AGO RICHARD WAS HOMES DRUG
ADDICTED AND SEEKING MEDICAL
HELP AT ONE OF CONNECTS
NEIGHBORHOOD FAIRS. THANKS TO
THIS PROGRAM RICHARD GOT CLEAN.
THANK DISABILITY SUPPORT ANY
ULTIMATELY MOVED INTO
SUBSIDIZED PERMANENT HOUSES
THIS TIME HE WAS BACK AS A
VOLUNTEER. THREE FOR THREE
YEARS NOW HE'S BEEN BACK
VOLUNTARY PASSING UP FREE
READING GLASSES TO PEOPLE IN
NEED WHILE I WAS THERE. RICHARD
HOW MANY TEARS IN HIS EYES CAME
UP AND SAID THANKS TO THIS
PROGRAM I NOW HAVE A HOME I OWN
I AM PROUD THAT RICHARD MADE UP
HERE TODAY RICHARD WOULD YOU
STAND.
WHICH IS STORY REMINDS
US THERE ARE NO OLD LOST
CAUSES. IN OUR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY. IT IS AN DURING.
CALIFORNIA VALUE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA HAS VALUE. SO WHEN
CRITICS ONE CRITIC CRITICS TELL
YEAH HOMELESSNESS CAN'T BE
SOLVED. INTRODUCED AND PEOPLE
LIKE RICHARD THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS THAT ARE LIVING
TESTAMENT THAT IT CAN'T I DON'T
THINK HOMELESSNESS CAN BE
SOLVED I KNOW THAT HOMELESSNESS
CAN BE SIGNED. FOR ME. OKAY.
WE
ARE BACK IN REGULAR SESSION
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTIETH FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING SHALL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN ALL MOTIONS TO BE
CONTINUED I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
THIS. THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTIETH AT NINE AM THE CORN
CALL CORN BECAUSE THE.